hey free code camp we're going to build
a coronavirus tracking app
and we'll do it in the style of a really
popular stock trading app called
robinhood
we're going to cover how to use
different third-party libraries in your
android app
we'll talk about method decomposition
and reuse and
we'll look at how do you make api calls
using a library called retrofit
covid19 has dramatically changed what
any of us thought 2020 would look like
and all the data indicates that
coronavirus will continue to impact our
society in a very meaningful way
for a lot of 2021 as well
as engineers or app developers the best
thing we can do
is look at the data for covid19 and
understand it
and display it to other people so we can
all become more educated about this
virus unfortunately google play
decided to prohibit all kovid 19 related
apps
unless they're from a government or
medical institution
so i decided to build my own covid19
tracking app
and i'm going to show you how to build
it as well our app uses the same ui
components
as the robinhood stock trading app and
the whole app is going to be
written in less than 200 lines of kotlin
code
let me do a demo of the app the purpose
of what we're building
is to be able to quickly see trends
around the growth of current virus
both at the national level and state
level by default when we open up the app
we're displaying the number of positive
covid 19 cases nationwide or across the
whole us
and i have the ability up here to toggle
between the number of negative cases per
day
number of positive cases or number of
deaths per day and you'll notice that
notice that the graph animates in
down here we have the ability to toggle
between the different time scales
so maximum means display all the data we
get back from the api which is generally
starting from around march
one month means the most recent one
month of data in one week means most of
the
most recent week of data by default
we're showing maximum
the other option i have is to actually
scrub on the chart on this line chart
and you'll notice that we update the
metric the individual metric number
shown down here it animates in and it
displays the exact
quantity of this metric on that day so
on april 25th
2020 though there were roughly 1800
deaths in the u.s
i also have the ability to dive into a
particular state
so for example in california you can see
that there's been a recent
increasing trend in number of positive
cases per day in california
and the same things apply i could also
dive into the number of negative cases
in california
or number of deaths and if i wanted to
look at
a particular day i can scrub over the
graph and you can see how the text
animates in down here
if you keep watching you'll learn how to
build exactly this step-by-step
the data for our app is coming from the
covid tracking project which is the most
reliable data source i could find
for getting daily updates on the number
of chronovirus cases
two of the core components in our
application this
chart which is called a spark chart
along with
this changing text view called a ticker
view both of them
are coming from open source projects
from the robinhood app
both the robinhood app and our app are
displaying the change of a metric
over time stocks versus chronovirus
cases
so there's a natural fit to using the
same components that they're using in
the robinhood app
and robinhood is considered one of the
best design android apps out there so
there's a lot to learn
from what they're doing i hope you're as
excited as i am to start building this
project
in the next video we're going to fetch
data using retrofit
from the covid tracking project api
our goal in this video is to talk to the
covid tracking project api
in order to retrieve the data that we
need for our application
the way we'll go about doing this is by
using the
api created by the kobe tracking project
our phone or our application is the
client and we're going to be making a
request
to the covet tracking project and
getting a response which contains the
data
we're going to be making a get request
on this particular url
api v1 slash us daily.json
and what that represents is we want to
retrieve
the daily data of the number of
chronovirus cases
nationwide and the covid tracking
project will respond with json data
and that json data will contain the
metrics for each day up until
the most recent day in addition to
getting the data nationally we'd also
like to be able to get
the per state data for coronavirus and
in order to do that
there's one more endpoint in the api
that we'll need to hit
and that will give us back a list of the
data per day
per state now we have an idea of what
we're trying to do
we can start the implementation we're
going to use a library called retrofit
on android
which makes working with apis really
straightforward
what i have here is a totally empty
android project so if i run it now
you'll see the emulator showing the
hello world application
the first thing i'm going to do is go
into the android manifest file and
because we're talking to an api over the
internet we need the internet permission
in our application
let's start typing users permission
internet
the next step is to include retrofit in
our project
so what i have open here is the official
site for retrofit which is a library
developed by square
and i'm going to go to the download
section so we can figure out how can we
include this
library into our project so here you can
see it says
for gradle which is what we're using you
need to include this line
i'm going to copy this and notice that
it says insert latest version here so
we're going to fill that in later
but i'm going to go into our project and
go into build.gradle
and make sure you're going into the
build.gradle which is located in the app
module
and then in the dependencies section i'm
going to add one more dependency
which is for retrofit in order to get
the latest version
i'm going to open up github
and tap on releases and you can see that
the most recent release is 2.9.0
so let's replace this with 2.9.0
one more thing that you'll need in order
to use retrofit is
a converter if i tap on the section
around retrofit configuration
the converters are used by retrofit to
translate the api response
into a model that we can work with in
our application and i'll talk more about
what that means later on
we're going to use json for this so i'll
copy the dependency for json
go back into android studio and paste
that in with the same version number
as what we used for retrofit finally the
last thing we'll need to do before we
can build our project
is instruct gradle to use java 1.8
and the reason for this is because more
recent versions of retrofit
use a component which uses a java 8
feature which are lambdas
so in order to enable java 8 we go up
into the
android section of the build.gradle file
hit enter a few times and we're going to
add a section here called compile
options
in this section we're going to have two
lines one for source compatibility
and the other for target compatibility
and for both of these
the value was going to be java version
version 1.8
at this point it's worth making sure
that we haven't screwed up yet so i'm
going to tap sync now
and we see a sync success the next thing
is let's build our project and we don't
expect any ui or functional changes but
we should still be able to build the
project and see hello world
in order to use retrofit the first thing
i like to do is define
a new file which is an interface that
retrofit will consume
in order to talk to our api the way that
works is
we want to create a new interface file
in the same directory where main
activity is located
let's define a new file here a new
kotlin file
and call this covid service
[Music]
the idea of this kovic service interface
is that we're going to have one function
defined here
for each endpoint in the apf so like we
talked about earlier there are two
endpoints that we're interested in
one which is for getting the national
data per day and i'll call that get
national data
and the other is for getting the per
state data and i'll call that getstate's
data
plural because we're getting the data
across multiple states
the way retrofit works is that we need
to add in a corresponding annotation
for each method defined in our interface
so for example
we're doing a get request on the
endpoint
us daily.json for getting all the
national data
next we'll add a return value for each
method that we've defined
retrofit and json will automatically
take the json data returned from the api
and turn that into data models that we
can use in our application
this is going to be enclosed in
something called a call object that
retrofit gives to us
and then our job is to define the data
class that we'll actually be using in
our application
and i'll call that covet data so we're
going to have the return value be a call
which is a list of covet data because
there will be
one element in the data we get back for
each day the return value for the other
function in our interface is going to be
the same
a list of covadata and i'll show that to
you later and the annotation is going to
be similar again
except for the endpoint is states
daily.json instead of us
one thing that's worth noting about this
api which is really nice
is that there's no authentication or api
key that you need in order to use it
so now let's define this data class
covet data
i'm going to again open up the project
tool window and let's define a new
kotlin file which defines covet data
cova data class is going to be a data
class
which represents the data that we care
about from the json
object in the api
[Music]
we're going to use a annotation called
serialize name which defines
the mapping of the json key to the
variable that we want to map it to
in our data class so for example there's
a key in the json object called
date checked and we're going to map that
to a string which is also called date
checked and i'm going to show you that
in the actual json result that we get
from the api
so what i have here is the documentation
for the covid
tracking project api and if you scroll
down
you can actually see the different
endpoints available in this api
the data that we're getting back right
now is historic us value
and we can issue the get request in the
browser in order to
dive into the json data and you can see
the data that we're getting back is
enclosed in this json
array that's what these square brackets
mean and
inside of this json array are different
json objects
this represents one day worth of covet
19 metrics
for the us the covad data class we've
defined in our project
represents one json object here and the
attribute that we've already parsed out
is this one called date checked so we're
actually parsing out this string
we're going to ignore a lot of the
attributes in the json object
but because we're interested in the
change per day
the attributes we are going to parse out
are negative increase
positive increase and depth increase in
addition when we are querying for
state data we're also going to care
about an attribute called state
so i'm going to include one attribute in
copa data
for each of the json keys that we just
talked about positive increase
negative increase and depth increase in
addition
we're also going to have one more key
for the us state that this data
represents
one optimization we can do is if the
serialized name
exactly matches with the name of the
variable we can
get rid of the serialized name
annotation and that's the case for
each attribute that we've defined i'm
going to go ahead and delete the
serializer name for all of them
one thing we should fix here is that the
positive increase negative increase in
death increase won't be of type string
but they'll actually be of type integer
because they represent the number
of new cases found in each of these
categories so now we've defined the cova
data class we can go back into covert
service and we can see that
the red underlines have gone away now we
can put all the pieces together
in main activity the oncreate function
will get called
by the android system when our
application boots up when our activity
is being created
at that point we want to make the api
request to fetch the national data
so we can display a chart on the screen
showing it
we'd also like to get the state data
because as soon as we get the state data
back we can populate our
drop down or spinner so the user is able
to drill down into a particular state
here's where we're going to use retrofit
the first thing we'll do is
create an instance of json using the
json builder
because we're going to need that to
create an instance of retrofit
we use the retrofit builder passed in a
base url which i'm going to do shortly
and add in a converter factory where we
pass in
the json converter factory and pass in
the json object
and then we can call dot build we can
now use
the coded service class that we created
in order to create
an instance of the copied service and on
this we can call
the methods that we had defined and i'll
get to that in a little bit but first
let's go back and define
the base url as a constant up here
[Music]
so in cobit service we defined the end
of the url which is us
daily.json and if we go back to the
browser you can see that that
basically captured this last portion of
the url
the base url will be everything except
for that which will be this
portion in the beginning so i can
capture that put it here and let's add
this in
in our retrofit builder
let's go back and uncomment this covet
service like a national data
and i mentioned how in kobit service the
return value
is not the model data directly but
something which is graphed inside
of a retrofit call object and the reason
for this
is because of the asynchronous nature of
doing anything with network calls
so we get back this call object because
that is how
we get notified of the success or
failure
of our api request so
on the call object that we get back
we'll enqueue a callback
and this callback will be parameterized
by list of cova data we're going to copy
that in
we can now override the methods that are
required
as part of the callback so if i tap on
the red light bulb we can have android
studio help us
implement these members there are two
methods on failure and unresponsible
override both them and in on failure all
we want to do is log an error
something went wrong with api call so
we're going to put a log.e which means
log at error level put the tag and then
indicate on failure and also include the
throwable t
which is included so let's define the
tag at the top of the file
and my convention for that is always to
have the tag name be the class name
for the on response method the first
thing we'll do is simply log
at info level that we entered into the
onresponse method
and we'll also include the actual
response that we get back
next the body of the response will
contain
the list of copa data that we should
have been able to parse
from the api if this data which
represents the national data
is null that means we got an invalid
response from the server and we should
log something
at warning level the log.w and just
indicate
that something went wrong
once we've gotten past this if statement
we know at this point that our data is
valid what we'll do here is save the
national data
into a member variable which is
accessible throughout the whole
main activity class so i'm going to
define national daily data
and define that as a property on main
activity
and this is going to create for us a
late
init var national daily data which is a
list of coveted data
one important point here is that the
data we get back from the api
starts with the most recent data however
for graphing purposes we'd like to start
our data
with the oldest data first and so we're
going to call nationaldata.reverse in
order to get the proper ordering
for now the only other thing i'll do in
this method is
add a log statement which indicates that
we're going to figure out in a
subsequent video how to take this
national daily data
and display it in a line chart to finish
off this video
i want to also fetch the state data and
then validate
that this is actually working what we've
done so far is used retrofit
to talk to the api and automatically
convert the json data we get back
into a class we defined called covadata
which includes attributes such as a date
of when this data is relevant number of
positive cases negative cases debts
and when we talk to the state endpoint
we also want to know the state that this
data is relevant for
so i'm going to represent this in this
light orange
blob which has covered data inside of it
and it contains a particular date
what we just did for the national daily
data is we reversed the order of the
list
that we got back from the api so the
oldest covet data is at the front of the
list
and the most recent is at the end of the
so a similar logic applies for the state
data
but there is a wrinkle because all the
state data is combined in one large list
we'll get all the data for all states
for may 1st
then may 2nd and then and so on and so
forth
however in terms of being able to graph
the data all really care about for
example
is being able to retrieve all of the
data relevant
for alaska and so what our job is is to
take this big list of data
and pull out all the data relevant to
alaska and put that into a separate list
so the idea is that we're going to take
this big list and break it down
into a map and that map will have a key
of the state
and the value will be all the coveted
data
relevant to that state so with that
understanding now we can
define the state data so i'm going to
do something quite similar so i'll say
coverage service dot
get states data and cue it
and this is actually going to be quite
similar so i'm going to initially just
copy all this
[Music]
and we're going to leave the log
messages here but instead of calling the
return value of response.body as
national data
this should be called states data
similar to what we had before we first
want to reverse the whole list we get
back
but then we want to group this large
list
down on a per state basis we're going to
call this nice
group by method in kotlin and pass in
the argument that we want to group by
and that'll be
the state attribute of every covat data
object
so this is actually going to return to
us a map rather than a list
so i'm going to call this per state
daily data and i'm going to create a
property
inside of main activity so again this
can be accessed throughout the whole
class which we're going to use in
subsequent videos
this is a map between a string which is
a state and a list of copa data
which is the chronologically increasing
cover data over time
once we've computed this per state daily
data the next thing is we'll want to
update that drop down or that spinner
with the state data
so that will happen in a later video
before we try this out the last thing i
like to do is make
one small improvement if you go back to
kova data you'll notice that this
attribute date checked is a string
however in order to do computation and
make it easier to display this date in
different ways
we would actually like to have this date
check to be of type
date java util date rather than a string
and so in order to make that happen i
can define it as a date here
but we need to pass in another
method in the json builder so json will
know how to convert
the date string and turn it into a java
date object
that can be done by calling this method
set date format
and you pass in a pattern the pattern
that the api we're working with
complies with is the following
so with that we should be able to
properly parse out dates
all right so now we can finally try this
out what i want to do to validate that
we have
something working is go into the
unresponse method
and where we have a log statement once
we've computed
the national daily data let's put a
break point right there
and now instead of running the app like
normal hit this button for debug app
so as soon as our program installs and
we get into this onresponse method
our program should halt execution at
this point and so you can see that that
happened
here we can take a look at what is the
value of this variable national daily
data that we just computed
so you can see that the size of this
list is 134
which is sensible because that means
that we have 134
days worth of data and if i expand this
we should ideally see all this
sorted chronologically so the oldest day
is january 22nd
january 23rd so it is ordered which is
great and it goes all the way up
until the most recent day so this gives
us confidence that
we are able to parse all the data
properly and you can also see the other
values like positive increase negative
increase death increase
those are also being parsed out properly
here
now that we have the data which will
power our whole application
in the next video we are going to build
out the ui which will display
the chart and the metrics our goal in
this video
is to update activitymain.xml which
defines the ui
for our application and update it to
include the different
components that we'll need for our
coronavirus tracker
once we've done that in the next video
we'll be able to wire things together
and actually have
the data that we parsed out in the last
video together with the
ui component that we had in this video
and be able to show something
on the screen taking a look at the final
ui of our application
there are a couple different ui
components on the screen at the top you
have
the label for this drop down and they
also have a drop down which is called a
spinner on android
for the purpose of this video i'm going
to ignore that spinner and just have the
state text view shown there below that
we have
something called a radio button group
and the radio button group
contains three different radio buttons
and the idea of a radio button is that
it acts somewhat like a normal button
except for you can only have one out of
those three buttons in that group
selected which makes sense because we
only want to be able to graph one of
these
metrics in our line chart below below
that we have a line chart
and in particular this is called a spark
chart and we'll talk about how to
integrate the robin hood library
to include this below that we have one
more radio group which has three radio
buttons and then finally at the very
bottom you have two text views
one which is for the date of what metric
is being
shown then to the right of that we have
the metric corresponding to that date
here's the default activity main that
comes in with any empty project
the first thing i'm going to do is
delete the default hello world text view
and instead bring over one more text
view
and for now i'm just going to go into
the design tab we're going to toggle
between the design tab and code tab
quite frequently and just to give myself
more room i'm going to open up the
design tab and make that the only thing
shown on the screen
so we have this textview on the ui
i'm going to call this tv and id of tv
select state
gives us a text of state and then have
it be
16 dp to the from the top and left
let's also make the text larger the text
appearance large
next i'd like to bring onto the screen a
radio button group
so i'm going to go into the button
section and
bring over a radio group and then have
the width of this radio button group be
match parent the whole width
let's zoom in a little bit have this be
constrained to the
bottom of the state text view
and then inside this radio group we want
three radio buttons so i'm going to take
the radio button and drag it inside of
the radio group
in the component tree the first video
button will be radio button
negative this will have a text of
negative
and also let's make the layout with wrap
content rather than match parent so it
shrinks
let's copy over this radio button two
more times so
we'll have one more for radio button
positive the text will be positive
and then one more for radio button
death
in order to have these radio buttons be
horizontal rather than vertical we need
to set the orientation attribute of the
radial group
and it looks like the width here should
also be wrapped content
same as this
[Music]
and then also we want to center the
contents of the radio group
inside of it so i'm going to select the
radio group one more time
and set the gravity attribute
and have the gravity be center and then
apply so now you can see that it
is in the center both horizontally and
vertically
below this radio group we'd like to have
a line chart which shows the
data on a per day basis so to do that
we're going to use a
library from robinhood an open source
library called spark
and this is a library to show a simple
android sparkline
chart view so if you scroll down to the
very bottom
then we can copy over this line that
we're going to add into our gradle build
file
i'm going to open up the
build.gradle file it's located in the
app module
add that in and then tap on sync now
while that's syncing let's go back to
github and we can see how to use this
there's a section here about usage all
we need to do to include this
spark chart in our application is add
the spark view to the layout
then going back into android studio we
can open up the activity main.xml file
and to add the sparkvue i want to go
into the code tab
so if we can just start typing sparkvue
here and then android studio will help
us with autocomplete the width will be
matched parent because we wanted to take
up the whole width of the screen
and the height for now it's going to
hard code in 150 dp and we'll change
that later
[Music]
one thing we need to do also is we're
going to position the sparkvue
vertically below the radio group above
it so
i added this id on the radio group
called radio group metric selection
so now we can say the top constraint
is to the bottom of the radio group
metric selection
we'll also give the sparkvue an id of
sparkvue
so let's see what this looks like in the
design tab so you can see that we have
a space allocated for the spark view
below the spark view we have one more
radio group
and this is going to be vertically
positioned below the spark view
we'll give this radio group an id of
radio group time selection because it'll
be used to select the time range of the
spark chart
we'll add a 16 dp top margin on the
radio group and then we're going to do
something very similar to what we had
before
we add in 3d radio buttons update the
text and id
and position them so that the radio
group is horizontal
the three time scales that we're going
to allow the user to pick from are
the most recent one week most recent one
month and the maximum amount of data
that we get returned
from the covet tracking project api as
of today
the max will typically be a period of
around four or five months because we
start getting data back from the api
around january or february the last
thing we need to do to complete
our basic layout is add the two text
views at the bottom of the screen and
these will be relative to the bottom of
the
parent or the screen and not relative to
the elements above it so we'll drag out
a text view
have this be 16 dp from the left end of
the screen
and concentrate to the bottom and let's
also give this a height a hard-coded
height of 80 dp
this will be a text view for the date
the date label
and let's change the text appearance a
little bit to make it body one
let's have one more text view which is
also 80 dp tall
the same exact height and this text view
is going to contain the
metric value we'll say tv metric
label
this is going to be relative to the
right end of the
tv date label and it'll be
to the bottom of the parent
the gravity for both of these text views
is going to be center
and this text view is going to extend
the
whole remaining width of the screen
which is not taken up by the first text
view
let's provide some sample data for each
text view for example
this metric it might let's get rid of
the text
attribute and let's use the tools
namespace
here which is this wrench text and
let's put in a sample data point of 4354
just to see how it might look let's make
this text bigger
we'll say display one as a text
appearance so it
becomes a lot bigger and then for this
text view over here
let's also put in a sample date may 30th
2020.
our goal now is to have the sparkvue
take up
all of the height remaining in the
screen once
all the other widgets are placed so the
way we'll do this is actually
allocate the widgets above the sparkvue
and below the sparkvue and have them be
glued to the top or bottom of the screen
so rather than having this radio group
be relative to the bottom of the
sparkvue i'm instead
going to delete that constraint the top
constraint
and have that instead be to the top of
the bottom components that we have
like that now i'm going to
set the bottom of the sparkvue to be the
top of
this radio group and instead of
hardcoding the height to be 150 now we
can just say
match constraint and that should now
fill up the sparkvue to be all the
remaining height
so now we have completed the basic
layout for our covet tracker
in the next video we're going to go back
into main activity and fill out this to
do so we're going to get rid of this to
do and actually
reference the sparkvue that we put on
the layout and populate it with
the national daily data that we parsed
out from the previous video
i'll leave a link in the description to
the code we wrote in this video
so you can take a look at the raw xml if
you want
where we left off in the last video is
we created the basic layout for our
covid tracker application
our goal in this video is to populate
this
graph to update the sparkvue with the
data we get back
with the national per day data of
chronovirus cases
in the code what that means is we want
to get rid of this to do item
and replace it with the actual code to
render the
spark chart i'm going to delegate the
work of updating the
spark chart with our national daily data
into a separate method
called update display with data this
will take in as a parameter
the national daily data and then i'll
have android studio help me to create
this method so i'll hit that red light
bulb
and then create the function inside of
main activity
instead of calling this parameter
national daily data i'm going to call it
daily data because we're also going to
reuse this method
for the per state data this is a list of
covada which is a data class that we had
defined earlier
there are three things that we want to
do inside of this method first in order
to render data
inside of the spark chart we need to
create a spark adapter
next we want to update the radio buttons
so by default the
positive cases and maximum time range is
selected
and third we want to display the metric
for the most recent
day of data that we have
let's start backwards so the first thing
we'll do is display
at the bottom of the screen the metric
for the most recent date again i'm going
to delegate the work of this into
another
function i'll call this update info for
date
and what we're going to pass in here is
a particular day of data
and the data that we want to pass in
here is the most recent date and because
our data is ordered chronologically
we can pass in daily data and pass in
the last
element i'll i'll have android studio
help us again to create this method
and we're going to call this covet data
the parameter
so the objective of this function is to
update the two text views at the bottom
of the screen
with the data inside of this parameter
so
first is the metric we call this tv
metric label that's referring to the
text view
at the bottom right of the screen and
the text attribute
of this textview is going to be the
number of coronavirus cases either
positive negative
or number of deaths on that particular
day for now because we're hard coding in
positive let's go with that that'll be
covered data
dot positive increase and
we actually want to format this number
with comma so it's
more human readable rather than just
showing the raw text
in order to do that we're going to use a
convenient class called number format
so we'll call number
format.instance.format and the format
method on number format
takes in a number and it will
automatically format it
to include the commas and decimals so
our covadata
has a date checked attribute which is a
javadate object
we want to take that javaday object and
turn it into
a nice string which looks something like
may 30
20. so the way we'll do that is with
something called simple date format
and the first parameter here is the
pattern of the date
so what we care about is the month which
will be
capital ms so three of those letters so
for example if it's marked it would be
mar
then we have the particular day in the
month followed by the year
and that's denoted by the lowercase y
the next parameter is the we had to pass
in a locale
we'll put in locale us and we're going
to save this in
a variable called output date format
that we have this output date format we
can use that to format
the javadate object inside of our
covadata
[Music]
and this is going to be a string which
we will put into
the text attribute of our text view and
we called it tv
date label
let's continue working backwards the
next step is to update the radio buttons
to select
the positive cases and max time radio
buttons by default this is actually very
straightforward
because all we need to do is specify the
particular radio buttons which should be
checked that's the attribute name to
indicate that it should be selected
so i'll say radio button positive
and that is checked attribute should be
true
and then similarly for radio button max
[Music]
let's run the app now and see how it
looks
so you can see as soon as the network
requests to fetch the national daily
data came back then we execute the logic
inside of the update display with data
method
and that is what is updating the bottom
text views with the
particular date along with the metric
and also these radio buttons finally the
last thing we'll do
is create a new spark adapter which will
instruct the sparkvue in our layout
how to render the data contained inside
of this
list of coveted data so i'm going to
pretend like we already have the spark
adapter class i'm going to call it covid
spark adapter and we're going to
construct a new instance of this
coveted spark adapter and this will take
in the constructor
the list of daily data that we have
we'll save this into a
local variable called adapter and now
i'll tap on this red light bulb and have
industry to help us to create
this class we'll extract it to a
separate file in the same package which
is fine
we can leave the parameter name as daily
data and we can see that this file did
indeed
get generated inside of the same
directory same package where main
activity is located so we have this
kovid spark adapter
this coveted spark adapter has to be a
subclass or has to inherit
from the spark adapter class which came
in
from the open source library so we're
going to put a colon here and say spark
adapter
[Music]
and we'll need to import this and you
can see that it does come in from the
robinhood library
and now there's a red underline under
the declaration the class kovid spark
adapter
if we tap on the red light bulb we can
see how to fix the problem which is by
implementing these three members
spark adapter is an abstract class so we
need to provide an implementation for
these three methods
and if we tap on ok android studio helps
us by automatically defining these three
methods with the proper parameter and
return type
because we passed in the daily data in
the constructor it's straightforward to
implement each of these three methods
so i'm going to first change the daily
data to be a private
member variable so i'm going to call it
a private val the easiest method is get
count because this is simply going to be
the size of the list so because it's a
one line statement we can use
this nice feature in kotlin to get rid
of the method body and just say
getcount is equal to dailydata.size
the idea of getitem is that given an
index which is a position
in the list of data we would like to
return any which means
a generic object which represents the
data object
at that position so again this is
actually one line you can just index
into
the list of daily data so i'm going to
get rid of the body of the function
and say get item at that particular
index is equal to
daily data at index
[Music]
finally is get y and the idea here is
that given a particular position
in the graph we want to retrieve the
corresponding value
at that position right now we're only
going to be graphing the number of
positive cases per day
so given an index you can grab the
corresponding cova data
at that position
[Music]
i'm going to put that into a local
variable called chosen day data and then
our job is simply to return
the positive increase that attribute on
that
covet data the return type of get y is a
float but
this attribute is of type int and so to
create turn it into a float we just call
the two float method
so we defined the basic working version
of the spark adapter we can go back into
main activity the error goes away
and now we have one more line to write
which is we have to grab a reference to
the sparkvue
and set the adapter property to be the
adapter that we just defined
that's it let's try it out
when the app boots up you can see that
we are graphing now in this spark chart
the number of positive coronavirus cases
nationwide
over the maximum time range and at the
bottom of
our application we're showing the
particular
data the particular metric for the most
recent day
now that we have the ability to show one
chart on the screen
we're going to extend this functionality
so that we're able to respond to changes
in radio button click in this video our
goal is to
make this spark line chart more
interactive so that we update it
when the user taps on any one of these
radio buttons for either selecting a
different metric to show or selecting a
different time scale
the way we'll go about doing this is to
map the radio button selection
to an enum which represents the metric
or the time scale
i want to create a new class called
chart options
and this chart options kt file will
encapsulate
all the knowledge about the different
ways we could render
this chart this spark chart and there's
going to be two enums inside of this
chart options class the first will be
for
the metric being shown and there are
three possible metrics that we can show
on the graph
one is negative negative cases of
coronavirus
one is positive cases of coronavirus and
then lastly is
the number of deaths
the other enum we'll define here is the
bottom row of radio buttons which are
the
time period over which the chart should
display data we're going to call this
enum class time scale
[Music]
and this enum is going to have an
associated integer
which represents how many days does time
scale represent
i'm going to call this val num date and
this is going to be an integer
so there are three possible options in
the bottom row of radio buttons one is
for one week of data and the
corresponding enum is seven days for
that
then we have one month and we're gonna
assume that one month
is always 30 days and then finally is
maximum which means
show the max amount of data possible we
don't know ahead of time the number of
days
associated with the maximum time so
we're going to instead put a special
value which is going to be negative 1.
the combination of these two enums
metric and time scale
cover all the possible ways that our
chart our spark chart
could be rendering data there's also a
notion of
our chart having a certain state
our chart has to be displaying one of
these metrics and it has to be
displaying data
over exactly one of these three time
scales
that state will live inside of the
adapter for
our chart so inside of the adapter class
i'm going to define
two variables here one for the metric
[Music]
and this is going to be by default
showing the positive cases
and notice that this is a var not a
valve because we do expect that this
metric will change
over time as the user taps on one of
those radio buttons in the top
group and there's one more variable
which is
the number of days ago and this is by
default going to be
the maximum time scale
[Music]
now that we've defined these two
variables our adapter is now
aware of what it should be rendering in
the spark chart
so in the function get y which returns a
float
of the corresponding metric value at
this position
at index instead of always returning the
positive cases of chronovirus we should
instead check
the value of the metric variable
i'm going to use the when construct in
kotlin and we'll return a different
value
depending on the metric we'll say return
when
and depending on the metric we'll do
something different when the metric
is negative then we want to return
the negative increase dot to float
when the metric is positive we want to
do something quite similar
except this should be positive increase
and then
when the metric is death we want to
report the number of deaths on that
particular day
[Music]
and then later on we're going to use
days ago in another function that we
override
on the adapter there's one more place
back in main activity where we
hard coded in the assumption of always
returning the positive number of
chronovirus cases
so here as well in this update info for
date method
we want to again check the metric enum
in our adapter and then return the
corresponding metric
so in order to have access to the
adapter inside of this method
instead of defining it locally here i
would like to make it a property so i'm
going to delete the val and now
inroadstudio will show me this red light
bulb and i can
use android studio to create the
property for me
so now we have this adapter and
right here we want to do something quite
similar so val
num cases should be again something
which is based on the adapter dot the
metric
and if the metric is negative then we
want to return
the cova data which is a parameter
passed in here we want to
display the negative increase attribute
of this cova data class
and then in the case of positive you
want to show positive increase
and then finally in the case of death we
want to show
the number of increases in the number of
dots
so instead of always placing this value
in we can instead
show num cases
we haven't made any functional
differences in the app yet because
we haven't added any event listeners for
when the radio buttons are changed
so all that logic for listening to
changes in
any of the ui elements we're going to
put all that in a function called
set up event listeners i'll call that
method right here set up
event listener
[Music]
and we'll define this method inside of
mainactivity
the reason i'm calling this method here
is because we only want to make the ui
interactive when there is actually data
to show so as soon as we get the
success from our api call to get the
national data that's when we want to
hook up the radio buttons and the
ability to actually scrub on the graph
before that it doesn't make sense
so in setup event listeners there's two
things we want to do
first is we want to add a listener for
the user scrubbing on the chart
and second we'd like to respond to radio
button selected events
i'll leave what to do for the second
item because we'll get to that later in
order to allow the user to
scrub on the chart which basically means
hold down on the chart and drag
their finger over it the first thing we
need to do is
set the is scrub enabled attribute to be
true
and then we need to set a scrub listener
on the sparkvue
and as you can see here the parameter
that we are provided in this set scrub
listener
is a value which is a value
corresponding to
one data object in the chart
in particular if you go back to the
adapter you can see that the
item data that we get back is going to
be the return value of
this function get item and we're turning
back the
covet data element at that position so
going back into
my activity i'm going to call the
parameter here item data
and then the job here is in the body of
this function which will be invoked for
us
we want to update the ui with this
information
as a sanity check one thing we can do is
just check if the item data is indeed
cova data which it should be because
that's the only thing we're returning
but
this is kind of a safety check then we
can call the method we already defined
update info for date with this item data
so we're going to be updating that
bottom ui component to show
the date and the metric at that date
let's run this
so now if i hold down on the chart and i
move along
you can see that i am able to have this
vertical line show up and as i move it
along
you can see the values at the bottom get
updated so on april 18th i'm able to see
exactly
the number of positive chronovirus cases
nationwide
and this makes our application a lot
more useful because we're giving the
user an ability
to drill down into specific days the
last thing we'll do before hooking up
the event listener
for radio button taps is go back into
the kovid spark adapter and make use of
this days ago property
the idea of days ago is that we want to
change the time scale
of our graph to only show that amount of
data the way we'll do this is by
overriding
one more method in the spark adapter
class it's called
get data bounce
super.getdatabounds this invocation of
the parent method which already defines
this is going to return to us a rect f
or a rectangle composed of float
coordinates so i'm going to capture that
supervalue into a local variable called
bounds
and the idea here is that this rectangle
defined by bounds
will dictate what exactly is shown in
our spark chart
if you wanted to shorten or expand the
amount of data shown in the chart
all we need to do is update the left end
of this bounds
rectangle so we can say bounds dot left
is equal to instead of the whole data
which is count
from basically invoking this function
getcount instead of showing the whole
amount
we'll say count minus seven which means
top off
everything except the last seven days
worth of data the most
recent seven days worth of data and this
needs to be afloat so we would have to
call to float here
then we can return these modified bounds
of course we don't always want to
subtract seven from the count and only
show the last seven elements of the list
instead we'd like to change it based on
this days ago property
instead of having seven here we want to
get the
days ago variable get the corresponding
num days property out of that enum and
turn that into a float
this will work in the case of looking at
the last one week or one month of data
because the corresponding value of num
days will be 7 or 30. however when the
max option is selected
instead of reducing the amount of data
shown by subtracting from count we would
instead like to show all the data
so that's a special case where we'll say
if days ago
is not equal to time scale dot max
only then do we want to reduce the
amount of data shown
so if days ago is max scale bounds will
actually be unchanged
which is what we want now we're finished
laying the groundwork for being able to
respond to when the user
taps on the radio buttons we simply need
to modify the metric or days ago enum
inside of the adapter now we can go back
into mainactivity
and write the logic to respond to radio
button selected events
so let me remove the to do because we're
actually going to complete this item
right now
there are two radio button groups that
we're going to respond to the first
is the set of radio buttons on the
bottom of the screen which is
for selecting the time so radio group
time selection
we're going to set a unchecked change
listener so this
is going to invoke the body of this
function whenever
one of the radio buttons in that bottom
group has been selected
this method that's going to get invoked
has two parameters one which is group
which we don't care about so i'm going
to
change that name to be a underscore
followed by a checked id
and the checked id is the id of the
radio button that was selected
so the only thing that really needs to
happen here is we need to update the
days ago
property in our spark adapter
to be the corresponding value when one
of the radio buttons is tapped on
so for example if i tapped on the radio
button for one week
i should set adapter.days ago to be
timescale dot
week so rather than hard coding it of
course we should do this contingent upon
the value of checked id so we'll use the
when construct i'll say when checked id
and if the checked id is r dot id dot
radio button week
and we'll map that to timescale.week
if it's r dot id dot radio button month
then we'll set the time scale to be
month
and then otherwise the time scale is max
once we've updated the days ago the only
other thing we need to do is notify the
adapter that the data
the underlying data has changed so the
adapter knows to
re-render itself the other radio
button group is at the top of the screen
for displaying a metric
so we'll do something quite similar
radio groupmetricselection.set on check
change listener
you don't care about the group but we do
care about the checked id
so i'm going to do another blend based
on the tucked id
if the radio button is positive
[Music]
then we want to update the display
metric to be
positive so i'm going to actually
delegate the work of updating the
display metric
into a method called update display
metric
and i'll pass in positive here
let's also do the same thing for the
radio button negative
[Music]
and then finally for death radio button
death
let's define this method now
the only thing that needs to happen here
is something quite similar we're going
to update the
metric variable in the adapter to be the
selected metric
and then we'll notify the adapter that
the dataset has changed
let's try it
so by default we're seeing the
nationwide number of positive
coronavirus cases over the maximum time
scale
if i change the metric to be negative
you can see that
we are seeing a different chart and
similarly with the number of dates
i can also do the same thing for showing
only a certain period of data so one
month you can see that
i'm only seeing that last segment and
then week i only have
seven data points being shown here so
that looks like it's working
in the next video we'll make a few
improvements to the ui
when the radio button is selected and
we'll add in a spinner or a drop down
component
at the top of the screen which will
allow the user to
look at the data for a particular state
there are two things i'd like to do in
this video
one is i'd like to make some
improvements of what happens when i
change either the metric shown for the
spark chart or the time scale shown
and second i'd like to include a drop
down or a spinner component at the top
of the screen
which will show all the states and if
the user selects a particular state we
should update the
data shown in the chart for all the
covid
19 cases of that state so first
one thing you'll notice is that when i
change the metric being shown on the
graph
this bottom component this text view
doesn't get updated
so we're actually showing wrong
information here right this 20 000 is
for the number of positive cases of
chronovirus
on this particular day and not the
number of deaths so this should really
be updated
when this metric gets updated the way
we'll fix this
is by adding some logic in this method
update display metric
this method is invoked every time the
user changes
the metric shown on the graph
so what the logic we have here is doing
is updating the metric
on the adapter
we'd also like to reset the number
and the date shown in the bottom text
views
so really what we'd like to do is call
the method that we wrote
a while ago called update info for date
so the idea here is that
we want to pass in the last covet data
object and have this bottom component
show the most recent data the last day
of data that we have
along with the metric corresponding to
the
metric passed in here and that logic is
already built
inside of the update info for data class
so you can see that we're already
checking
the met adapter metric so we're going to
show the right value
the question now is how do we know what
to pass in here
the issue is that we need to know what
data is currently being displayed
in the sparkvue if the data being shown
as a national data
then we can take the last element of
that list of cova data representing the
national chronovirus data
and pass that into update info for date
for date
but if we're showing a particular
state's data we need to know
what state we're showing and grab the
last day's worth of data for that state
and pass that in
so we need to have some way of knowing
what is being shown currently
to do that we're going to add one more
property or member variable
inside of main activity i'm going to
define a property called
currently shown data
and this will hold on to the data that's
currently being
displayed inside of the sparkvue and the
reason i'm assigning the value here
is because this method update display
with data takes
in the list of data which is being shown
in the sparkvue so we know that this
method has to be called at the beginning
and every time that the data for the
sparkvue
has changed currently shown data is
going to be equal to
exactly the parameter passed into update
display data
now android studio can help us to define
this property
create property currently shown data
and now we can go back to update info
for
date and then pass in the last element
of the currently shown data one more
thing i'd like to do before we
try this out is a quick design
improvement based on the
metric being shown we can display a
different color for the chart
[Music]
so i'm going to add a comment here which
says update
the color of the chart and
what we want is there's an attribute on
the sparkvue called
line color and we want to set this to be
equal to some
color integer the way you get a color
integer is you can say
context compat dot get color
and you can pass in context which is
this and a color resource
so there is a predefined colored
resources like r dot color dot
let's say color accent this will give us
back
a color inch
[Music]
and i'm going to actually add an
annotation here to make it obvious that
this
variable is of type coloring so we can
pass and color into here
and then also we can update the text
view which represents
the metric so we call that tv metric
label
and we're going to set the text color
color inch
so now based on the metric we want to
show a different color here rather than
just the color accent here are the
colors that
i picked out which i thought were
intuitive for each of the metric types
negative cases is green positive cases
is this orange color
and number of depths is this red color
so back in android studio
i'm going to paste in those hexadecimal
values
inside of the color resource file
so instead of resources values you
should already have a colors of xml and
we're going to add three more colors
here
[Music]
one will be color negative
and then this will have a value of the
green color
[Music]
then we'll have color positive this has
the orange value and finally we'll have
one more color representing
the death metric this has that red value
now now that we've defined these three
colors we can go back here and again
use the when construct the when
statement in kotlin
[Music]
we're going to define a color resource
which is the result
of this when statement instead of the
went statement for each metric we'll map
it to the color resource that we had so
for example
metric negative will map to
r.color.color negative
positive will be color positive and
death will be color depth
now we can use the colored res value
when we're obtaining the color int
using contextcompat.getcolor and finally
last thing we can do before we run this
is inside of this method update display
with data
we're calling update info for date we're
already calling this
method inside of update display metric
and we're actually doing other useful
things such as
updating the line color so rather than
calling
update info for date i'm instead going
to call
update display metric and pass in metric
positive
because that's that's always going to be
the default metric shown
let's try it
so now you can see when we run the app
initially we are again seeing the
positive cases of coronavirus over the
maximum time scale but we have
this nice color applied to it this
orange color if i change this
to be death we can see it gets updated
to red
and importantly the texture at the
bottom showing the exact metric for the
most recent day
has been updated to reflect the chosen
metric
the last major piece of functionality
for our app is allowing the user
to select which state they want to see
data for
so back in mainactivity this is
corresponding to
this to do item that we had left in one
of the prior videos
so we're finally going to do this i'm
going to remove the to do
and i'm going to delegate the work of
updating the spinner with the state
names
into a method called update
spinner with state data
and this function is going to take in
one parameter
which is the list of all the states to
show
and that will simply be the
key set of this map so if you recall
the per state daily data is a map
of each key being a state and the value
being
all of the coveted data for every day of
that
state so now we can
have android studio help us to define
this method i'll define it in main
activity
and i'll have the parameter be called
state names
and this is of type set of string the
objective here is
given these state names which are a set
we want to turn that into
an ordered list and we're going to take
that ordered list and
pass that in as the input to our
dropdown component
the first let's turn our set into an
ordered list where we're alphabetizing
all of the states so we'll call state
names dot to mutable list so we can
actually change and mutate the contents
of this list
we'll call this variable state
abbreviation list
and it will contain the abbreviations
for all 50 states plus
several u.s territories and
we want to alphabetize this list so we
want
states like alaska or alabama to show up
at the top and states like wyoming to
show
very at the very end of this drop down
so we'll call dot sort and then we also
want to have
one special entry in the state
abbreviation list which is to represent
the national data right we're not going
to get that in the
set of strings passed in here because
this only contains state names so we're
going to have to add it manually right
here
and this is going to be the very first
element in our list
so i'll add this at position 0 and i'm
going to have
a special entry which is called all
states
which basically means i want to see the
national data
so again android 3 will help us to
define this variable all states
and this is going to have a value
a hard coded value of all
nationwide and i'm actually going to
define this outside because i can make
this a const
so what we want to do next is take this
ordered state abbreviation list data
and add that as the data source to our
spinner
next we need to add the spinner into our
ui so going into activitymain.xml we
would like to be able to add
a spinner component at the very top of
this layout that we're building
i'm not a big fan of the built-in
android component for this which is
this spinner component i think it's
really hard to use and it doesn't look
that good
instead we're going to use a library
called nice spinner
and this is easier to work with and in
my opinion it looks better
so let's go down first to how to include
this
library into our project so inside of
the build.gradle file we need to add
a dependence like normal but also we
should add this section about
repositories so i'm going to go into
android studio
go into the build.gradle file which is
located inside of the app module
and you probably won't have a repository
section here
so right after we added compile options
let's add repositories
and we want to add this maven repository
i'm going to copy this line
and paste that in and now we should be
able to add the dependency
and copy this line and paste it in here
tap on sync now and hopefully we're able
to download this library properly
looks like it succeeded so now we can go
back into activity main and we can
include it
in this area that we allocated for it to
do this i'm going to go back
into the code view of our layout
and right here is the label which
describes
what this spinner is for i'm going to
create another
component which is called spinner and it
should be nice spinner we'll set the
layout width to be zero dp
because we want this knife spinner to
take up as much room as possible
the height can be wrap content
and we're also going to add a margin
start and end
there's a few other properties we can
add in here ellipse size we're going to
ellipses in the end
and the maximum number of lines
will be one and then the text appearance
of what we're showing
should be large and now our job is we
need to
constrain this view appropriately
for the horizontal constraint you want
the left end of the spinner to be up
against the right end
of the select state text view
so i'm going to say constraint start
is to the end of the tv
select state and then the end constraint
is going to be to the end of the parent
because we wanted to go to the end of
the screen for the vertical constraint
we're going to have the top
and bottom of the spinner be equivalent
to the top and bottom
of the select state text view which is
to the left
so bottom bottom of and then we want to
pass in cv select state
and then something quite similar for the
top
and one last attribute that i forgot to
add is something called pop-up text
alignment and i'm going to
put start here just so that in the
drop-down all of the
states are left aligned or start aligned
so if i go into the design tab now we
should see that there is a space
allocated
for the spinner
one thing we can do here is just give
this an id because we'll need to refer
to it
in our main activity.kotlin file we'll
call it spinner select
now we can go back into main activity
and let's reference
this spinner that we just added so i'll
say spinner select
dot attach data source and we'll pass in
the state abbreviation list
the last thing we need to do to hook it
all up is we'd like to be notified
when the user has selected another state
from the drop down
so on the spinner select widget we're
going to add a
set on spinner item selected listener
and this takes in four parameters the
only ones that we care about are the
parent and the positions i'm gonna
put an underscore in for the other
params
and this will now this method will be
invoked every time
a new item in this drop down is selected
so in order to get the selected state
we're going to say parent dot get item
at position it'll pass in position
and we know that this is going to be of
type string our data source for the
spinner
is a list of string i'm going to cast
this as a string
and save this as the selected state
now we'd like to get the corresponding
daily list
of cova data for that state
so i'll say per state daily data and
then we'll
look inside the map to pull out
all of the data relevant to that state
this is going to be
val selected data
the only thing we need to be careful
about here is that if the selected state
from the drop down is the all option
which is i want to see the data
nationally
then that element won't exist in the per
state daily data and we're going to get
a null value here
so if that happens we can use this
question mark colon operator to say if
the value here
was null then we would instead like to
assign the value of national daily data
to this variable
now that we have selected data which is
our list of covad data
across all the days available we can now
simply call
the method we already have called update
display with data
with selected data that should be it
let's try it out
perfect so now we're able to see this
drop down
and by default the all option is
selected which means we're seeing
data nationally and then all these state
abbreviations are what we're getting
back from the api
so for example i might look at the
california data which is ca
and we can see that the data does get
updated so the
text view down here to show the exact
metric value
is showing something significantly
smaller which is for california
and then if i choose different metrics
i'm again seeing the california specific
data
and the same functionality applies
across all states i can scrub
on the spark view i can change the time
scale
and i can choose any metric that i want
if you've gotten this far drop a comment
to let me know so i can congratulate you
on building out all the functionality
for our application
in the next video we're going to make a
couple design improvements for example
we're going to use one more robinhood
library called ticker in order to
animate changes to this text view
and we'll do a few other design and
color improvements in the app
at this point we're done with all the
functionality of our app
in this video we're going to go through
a couple of really easy
and high impact design improvements
first
in order to really make our app feel
like the robinhood stock trading app
we're going to use
a library called ticker in order to
animate changes into
this text view here's the github page
for robinhood ticker and you can kind of
see what this looks like
in this gif we're going to have the same
effect for our text view
if you scroll down all we need to do to
include this is add this into our
build.gradle file
so this is again going to go into the
build.gradle on the app module
tap on sync now and then let's go back
to github
and you can see it's really
straightforward to use this instead of
the text view we just need to replace
that
with a ticker view so let's go back to
android studio go into activity main
and that component that we wanted to
replace
instead of just being a text view we
would like this to be a ticker view so
go into the code view
go to the very bottom and this is what
we want to replace
so i'll say ticker view here and then i
also want to just
update the id and make this
particular view just so it's obvious
that this is the robinhood
ui component ticker view now the only
thing we need to do in order to properly
use the ticker view library is go into
main activity
and we we need to set a character list
on the ticker view
so in the method for setting up the
event listeners
let's add one more line here which is
for the ticker view and we're going to
set the character list there's a
predefined character list
called ticker utils
[Music]
dot provide number list because we're
going to be animating
over numbers so if we try this now
so i'm showing positive cases now i go
into the number of deaths
so you can see how the ticker view did
animate in this really nice way
and same thing with negative cases and
if i scrub over
the spark view you can see as i scroll
we're getting that really nice feedback
that this number is changing
one other quick design improvement we
can do is to add a background shading
color
behind the sparkvue and the time radio
group
the reason this is valuable is it
provides segmentation into our layout
and it gives a hint to the user about
which components are related to each
other
the way we'll go about doing this is by
adding some padding and margin between
the sparkvue and the
radio group time selection and then
adding a background color to those two
components
so going into activity
on this radio group which sits below the
spark view
that will add a margin top of
16 dp and we'll also add a
padding bottom of 8 dp
and for the sparkvue we are going to add
a padding
on the top of 16 dp
along with the padding bottom of 8 db
and these are the two components the
sparkvue and the radio group time
selection on which we're going to have a
background color i'm going to
assign a background and for now it'll
just be color primary but we're going to
update this
in just a bit once we define the color
so i'm going to actually call this
color background shade
and have the same color be defined here
and then let's have android studio help
us
create a color value resource the
resource value i'm going to put in here
is this very light gray light blue color
that i found
and basically what that did if i command
click in the color background shade is
it added one more color resource in our
colors.xml file
so if we try this now now you can see we
have this background color behind the
spark view and the time selection
and that makes it easier to comprehend
what we're looking at
the last major design improvement i
would like to make in this video
is to improve the ui of these radio
buttons
in our application the default radio
button ui on android
i think is pretty ugly so we're going to
modify it so it looks and feels like a
button
i have a separate video which talks
about a few of the aspects of
what we're about to do so i'll leave a
link to that if you're interested
but the idea is that we're going to
remove this
circle icon next to the radio button and
add a background drawable which is a
shape drawable
behind each of these radio buttons so
first let's fix the styling for a single
radio button
how about this negative radio button and
then we'll think about how can we apply
that style to all radio buttons in our
application
and i use the word styling deliberately
because instead of adding these
attributes directly onto the radio
button
i instead am going to define a style and
apply the style onto this radio button
so inside of the styles xml file which
you should already have
in the values directory in resources i'm
going to open that up
we're going to define a new style here
[Music]
and the name we'll call it custom radio
button
styles can have parents and parents are
basically where are you inheriting
all the different attributes and styles
from and
you can see the android studio is
suggesting for us that we
have the parent be widget app compat
compound button radio button which is
what we're going to pick
and inside of this style tag is we're
going to define various attributes in
order to remove that circle that shows
up by default on the radio button
we're going to override the android
button
item and we're going to set this to a
value of null
also why don't we set the text style
of the radio button to be bold
so i'm going to add this style this
custom radio button style
on the negative radio button that we had
and so i'm going to add the style
attribute and then reference the custom
radio button style
so if we try this now we should
hopefully no longer
see the circle next to the negative
icon yeah and you can see that that is
indeed the case and we're also bolding
the font
like we expect now going back into
styles xml
let's add one more attribute onto the
custom radio button
for the background and let's define a
drawable here
and we're going to create a brand new
drawable for now i'll just call this
button default
and then now let's have introduce help
us to create a drawable resource file
which is named appropriately the root
element
let's have that be shape and then tap on
ok
and so here is where we're going to
define different attributes of the
background for our radio button things
like
the corner radius the padding the the
shape like whether you want it to be a
square or oval
etc so there's a few different
attributes we're going to find here
one which is padding and we're going to
have the padding be
on all sides 12 dp
[Music]
and then one more attribute we're going
to have is
a radius of 4 dp a corner radius of 4 dp
[Music]
so if we go back into styles xml the
error has gone away and now we should be
able to see this button default as the
background for our
radio button but what we really would
like is
to change the background based on the
state of the button
if the radio button has been selected or
in the checked state that means
it's having an impact on what is being
rendered in the spark view we'd like to
show it
in a different way compared to in this
default way
just button default the way you can do
this
is through something called a state list
drawable
so we're going to have one more state
list which is a selector type
and the selector is basically going to
tell us
whether to use one background resource
file or another background resource
depending on the state of the underlying
widget
or radio button in this case so i'm
going to define
another drawable resource and call this
button
background and android studio will help
us to create a drawable resource file
but this time the new element will be a
selector
and the reason we want this to be a
selector is because this
button background xml is going to select
which
background we actually want to apply on
the radio button depending on the state
we only have really two states we care
about for the radio button
one which is um the default and so i'm
going to put that at the bottom of the
file and that's what we already defined
button default and then
if the button is in the checked state
that's the terminology for radio buttons
if the state checked is true
we want to create another drawable for
what the button should look like at that
point
so i'll say android drawable and this is
going to be
drawable button checked
[Music]
let's have android studio help us this
is going to also be of type
shape it'll be quite similar to
our previous button button by default
i'm going to copy over everything here
the only thing that will be different is
we're going to have a solid color
background
in the case that the radio button has
been selected
we're going to define this we'll call it
color
selected background
[Music]
and let's tap on the red light bulb and
create a color
value resource so i'm going to put in uh
this gray value that i found
and then i noticed that i misspelled use
android studio to help you refactor this
so back in button background let's add
the closing tag here and let's try it
out
so by default we're not really seeing
any difference but now when we
tap on the radio button you can see that
we are swapping out the background to
this darker
color in the back what we'd also like to
do is change the text color
so we're going to take a very similar
approach for that back in
styles xml we're going to define another
item which is called text color
and this is going to be a color state
list resource so i'm going to call this
color button text
and we're going to create a new color
resource file
and the root element will be a selector
so it's the same concept as a drawable
stateless resource
we're also going to have color state
list resources
here by default if the radio button is
not selected we're going to go into
default case
and we're going to pick color selected
background
so we're going to do the opposite of
what we're doing in the case of the
button
so by default we're going to have the
selected background color and
otherwise we're going to just use white
[Music]
the state checked is true then the color
becomes white
let's try it
so i tap on the negative radio button
and you can see that we are
able to properly swap out the text color
to make it white and make the background
that gray color so the next step is we'd
like to apply the same
style to each of the six radio buttons
in our app
so one approach is we could go back into
activity main
and then copy over this style line with
every single radio button
but then in the future if we had other
radio buttons we'll have to keep
remembering to add
this style line instead we're actually
going to make this part of the theme so
we don't even need to include it in any
radio button
i'm going to get rid of this line going
back into styles.xml
this style app theme defines the base
application theme and you can customize
it here so
there is a property called radio button
style
so i'm going to add one more item which
is android radio button style
and we're going to reference the custom
radio button style
let's try it so now if we've done the
job correctly
all six order buttons should be updated
to include this new style
there you can see we are we are seeing
that which is great
welcome to the very last video in the
covid tracking project
series so i want to start out by just
doing a really quick design improvement
to align the project that we have here
with what i showed you in the demo in
the very beginning so
i'm going to update the color scheme of
the
action bar color here and the color
shown in this notification window
both of these colors are defined in
colors xml
color primary dark and color primary
so the color primary i'm going to
actually make it
be identical to color selected
background
and color primary dark i'm going to make
it a
slightly darker gray and because color
selected background
is same as color primary i'm actually
going to
just make this a reference to color
primary
and one last thing in order to make it
pixel perfect
with the original demo app if we go into
activity main
we can add a margin top on the sparkvue
of 8dp let's try it
awesome so now you can see that we've
faded out and made the action bar less
noticeable so that
the main attraction of our app is
the spark view and the metric being
shown
finally the very last code change we're
going to make in this project is
updating the text that's shown in the
action bar
instead of saying covet tracker i wanted
to say code 19
cases per day so that the user has an
idea of what they're looking at
so main activity inside of oncreate
right after the set content view
we can just say support action bar
dot title is equal to and we're going to
pass in
r dot string dot app description
the app description is a string resource
that we're going to create
the resource value will be covered 19
cases per day hit enter
support action bar might be null so
we're going to wrap that in a question
mark
and we need to actually get the string
value
out of the string resource and that's
straightforward we just need to say get
string
and pass in that resource try it
all right and now you can see the action
bar did get updated properly
there are a lot of natural extension
ideas for this project
for example right now we're only showing
us data and u.s states
but you might be interested in for
example the
chronovirus cases in india and that
would be
a really natural thing that you could
build on this app by talking to a
different api
another thing you might think about is
instead of showing the delta per day we
might want to
see the cumulative data from the first
chronovirus case
up until today and there's no way to do
that now but you might imagine having
some sort of toggle
and finally we're making a network
request
every time we open up the app however
the data only
gets updated once per day and so you can
imagine
implementing a local database where we
cache all the data
so you could implement something like a
room database in
our application store all the data and
if you don't have an internet connection
or if the
api request is unnecessary we can simply
grab the data from our database
to recap we covered a lot of ground in
building out
our robinhood style coronavirus tracking
app
first we used retrofit to talk to the
kobit tracking project which is the api
which provided all the data for our
application
next we used two libraries from
robinhood in order to build out the core
ui
of our application first was spark which
helped us to
graph this spark line chart in our
application
and showed the growth of chronovirus
cases negative positive
or debts on a per day basis and the
second library
was called ticker and that allows us to
animate
changes in a text view and finally we
used another library called nice spinner
in order to
have a better looking drop down menu a
better spinner
which shows all the state data and when
the user
selects a new state we update the ui
accordingly
if you've been following along and you
have your own working version
of this chronovirus tracking app i'd
love to hear from you in the comments
let me know how it went or if you
completed any extensions beyond what we
built
given that google still isn't allowing
kobit 19 tracking apps in the play store
i really hope that you're able to use
this mobile app as a way
to track the growth or hopefully the
decline
of coronavirus over time i'll leave a
link to the github repository in the
description
if you have any questions feel free to
let me know and i'll help as much as i
can
until next time stay safe and i'll see
you later
[Music]
bye